Nicous: 康大出来的其实不傻逼
Nicous: People from Kangda aren't actually stupid.
Nicous: 但是p不出来的很傻逼
Nicous: But those who don't come out are really stupid.
Choiszt: 卧槽你这么多环境
Choiszt: Damn, you have so many environments.
Jack: 怎么会这样
Jack: How could this happen?
Choiszt: 啥呀我看看
Choiszt: What is it? Let me see.
Nicous: 我会画一下
Nicous: I'll draw it out.
Jack: 唯独的图像
Jack: The only image.
Jack: 已经没有康大了
Jack: There's no Kangda anymore.
Choiszt: 配环境之神
Choiszt: With the god of environments.
Shure: 你是神吗
Shure: Are you a god?
Shure: 你真神吗
Shure: Are you really a god?
Katrina: 心里有
Katrina: In my heart, yes.
其他人：你看你这我
Others: Look at you.
其他人：我问他他肯定也问
Others: I asked him, he definitely asked too.
Shure: 我以前装过啥
Shure: What did I install before?
Shure: 我全忘了
Shure: I forgot everything.
Nicous: 我觉得你还不如现在先装
Nicous: I think you should just install it now.
Nicous: 然后看他就缺什么
Nicous: And then see what's missing.
Jack: 你是要
Jack: Do you want to...
Jack: 你是只要跑一段
Jack: You just need to run a bit.
Shure: 我不是我就是
Shure: No, I just...
Shure: 哎呀怎么说呢
Shure: How should I put it...
Shure: 就是
Shure: It's just...
Shure: 反正这个东西完全不是我自己写的
Shure: This thing wasn't written by me at all.
Shure: 我当时就
Shure: At that time...
Jack: 那你就缺啥你就造啥呗
Jack: Then just make whatever you need.
Shure: 行那我就
Shure: Alright, then I'll...
Nicous: 你为什么天天给我闻烟啊
Jack: 不会有那么强的环境感吧
Jack: It shouldn't have such a strong sense of environment, right?
Choiszt: 这不是想让你抽吗
Choiszt: Isn't it to make you smoke?
Nicous: 你他妈的
Nicous: You son of a...
Nicous: 你他妈国家烟草的吧
Nicous: Are you from the national tobacco company?
Jack: 我用过所有库里面
Jack: I've used everything in the library.
Jack: 我觉得除了sever那种傻逼库
Jack: 前后不兼容之外
Jack: It's not compatible back and forth.
Jack: 剩下库对版本没有任何依赖
Jack: The rest of the libraries have no version dependency.
Choiszt: 卧槽确实
Choiszt: Damn, indeed.
Jack: sever那个库真的很傻逼
Choiszt: 我觉得那个OPI那个库有点傻逼
Choiszt: I think the OPI library is a bit stupid.
Jack: 我当时我当时写这个
Jack: At that time, I wrote this...
Jack: 他不是那个他
Jack: He is not that guy.
Jack: 不用Flash
Jack: Don't use Flash.
Jack: 啊然后他两个版本之间
Jack: Ah, and between the two versions,
Jack: Flash tension two就enable
Jack: Flash tension two is enabled.
Jack: Flash tension two那个q word不一样
Jack: The q word for Flash tension two is different.
Jack: 然后
Jack: Then,
Jack: 然后就上一版本扣了copy过来
Jack: then copy from the previous version.
Jack: 就Flash tension two根本就没开
Jack: Flash tension two isn't even on.
Jack: 而且因为它是传在那个coalx里面啊
Jack: And because it's passed within the coalescence,
Jack: 所以它不会报错
Jack: it won't give an error.
Jack: 它会正常跑上去
Jack: It runs normally.
Jack: 但是速度慢两倍
Jack: But it's twice as slow.
Choiszt: 就是你根本没启动flag tension two
Choiszt: So, you never activated flag tension two.
Jack: 对但它不报错
Jack: Yeah, but it doesn't give an error.
Jack: 你你你跑一个你跑一个
Jack: You, you, you run one, you run one.
Jack: 看缺啥就行
Jack: Just see what's missing.
Jack: 缺啥装啥
Jack: Install what you need.
Jack: 这个这个是一定是最最快的
Jack: This, this must be the fastest way.
Nicous: 就是给你重温一下
Nicous: Just to refresh your memory.
Nicous: 巩固一下
Nicous: Reinforce it.
Nicous: 然后毕设
Nicous: Then for your project.
Nicous: 然后答辩提问你
Nicous: Then during the defense, they'll ask you.
Nicous: 你不就能说了
Nicous: And you can explain it.
Choiszt: 谁他妈毕设问你装啥
Choiszt: Who the hell asks what you installed for your project?
Shure: 我瞎他妈说
Shure: I'm just bullshitting.
Shure: 他不也也也不知道我装的什么
Shure: They won't know what I installed anyway.
Shure: 环境
Shure: The environment.
Nicous: 你要为你自己负责
Nicous: You have to take responsibility for yourself.
Shure: 你滚
Shure: Get lost.
Shure: 我以后我就他妈都不干这行了
Shure: I'm never doing this job again.
Nicous: 我以后就举报你
Nicous: I'll report you in the future.
Nicous: 毕设
Nicous: For your project.
Shure: 你经查吗
Shure: You want to check?
Nicous: 我全是自编的
Nicous: I made everything up.
Nicous: 你举报吧
Nicous: Report it.
Nicous: 一举报一个准
Nicous: Each report is a sure thing.
Jack: 举报毕设没用的
Jack: Reporting the project won't work.
Jack: 你必须要被选在那个系统里面举报他
Jack: You have to be selected in the system to report him.
Jack: 就他有一个什么什么毕业选
Jack: There's some sort of graduation selection.
Choiszt: 卧槽他那个写了就是什么伪造数据
Choiszt: Damn, he wrote that the data was fabricated.
Nicous: 没关系我的数据怎么是伪造的呢
Nicous: It's okay, how could my data be fake?
Nicous: 那只能说GPT太不稳定了
Nicous: It just means GPT is too unstable.
Jack: 0.2 哈哈哈
Jack: 0.2, hahaha
Jack: 0.2 就是的
Jack: 0.2, exactly.
Nicous: 没办法我就喜欢随机
Nicous: I can't help it, I just like randomness.
Jack: 他们这0.2套路
Jack: They have this 0.2 strategy.
Jack: p等于0.5
Jack: p equals 0.5
Choiszt: 哈哈哈这说的有道理
Choiszt: Hahaha, that makes sense.
Nicous: 不然我怎么改随机的
Nicous: Otherwise, how could I make it random?
Choiszt: 不是你out都在这上跑吗
Choiszt: Weren't you running OUT on this?
Jack: 这电脑这能跑
Jack: Can this computer even run it?
Nicous: 跑的inference是吧
Nicous: Running inference, right?
Nicous: 啊没有跑哎
Nicous: Ah, it's not running.
Choiszt: 这个怎么看显存
Choiszt: How do you check the VRAM?
Choiszt: 就是就是
Choiszt: Exactly, exactly.
Nicous: 怎么会有人看Mac的显存
Nicous: Who checks the VRAM on a Mac?
Nicous: 我真不能理解
Nicous: I really don't get it.
Shure: 它没有显存
Shure: It doesn't have VRAM.
Choiszt: Mac不是CPU GPU一块吗
Choiszt: Isn't Mac's CPU and GPU combined?
Shure: 对它算一个
Shure: Yeah, it's considered one.
Shure: 你把那活动监视器打开就能看了
Shure: You just open the Activity Monitor to check.
Choiszt: 嗯
Choiszt: Hmm.
Shure: 不是他们俩不分你知道吧
Shure: They don't separate, you know.
Nicous: 十六g对啊
Nicous: Sixteen gigs, right.
Nicous: 现在是不是18起步
Nicous: Isn't it starting from 18 gigs now?
Jake:搞定了吗
Jake: Got it done?
Choiszt: 十六g能跑个啥呢
Choiszt: What can you run with sixteen gigs?
Shure: 没没搞定
Shure: No, not done.
Shure: 但是可以可以进行下一个活动
Shure: But we can move on to the next activity.
Katrina: 是不是
Katrina: Right?
Katrina: 要让他们带一个自己的二手物品啊
Katrina: Should we have them bring their own second-hand items?
Shure: 啊对
Shure: Yeah.
Nicous: 十六g能跑啥呢
Nicous: What can you run with sixteen gigs?
其他人：别糟我的
Others: Don't mess with mine.
其他人：你去糟你的信任就行了
Others: Just mess with your own trust.
Jack: 我十六g
Jack: I have sixteen gigs.
Jack: 十六g已经可以跑千万1.8b哈哈
Jack: Sixteen gigs can already run a million 1.8b, hahaha.
Jack: 16G的显示
Jack: Sixteen gigs of display.
Choiszt: 还有账号吗
Choiszt: Do you still have an account?
Jake:还是没装上
Jake: Still couldn't install it.
Jack: 你你缺什么呢
Jack: What do you need?
Jake:你知道看这个数据集的人一般都会装
Jake: You know, people who look at this dataset usually pretend.
其他人：哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Others: Hahahahaha
Shure: 卧槽太侮辱我了吧
Shure: Damn, that's so insulting.
Jack: 这个数据一般都是装好才能收起来
Jack: Usually, this data is packed before it's stored.
Jack: 看一下你这感觉不缺啥呀
Jack: It looks like you don't need anything.
Shure: 肯定缺
Shure: Definitely need something.
Jack: 那你那你随便跑
Jack: Then just run whatever.
Jack: 你要跑哪个
Jack: Which one do you want to run?